foreign
dear president Lula it's a pleasure for
me to have you here in Brussels after
the very warm welcome I received in
Brasilia last month
I want to thank you for your
participation
at The selac Summit
your presence adds to a historic
dimension
it's the first summit between the
European Union and our Latin American
and Caribbean Partners in eight years
the world has certainly changed during
that time we went through a global
pandemic we have a major warm European
soil and we are confronted with the
generational challenge of climate change
so we need our close friends to be at
our side in these uncertain times and
therefore I welcome Brazil's
re-emergence as a major actor on the
global stage
it is Timely
and it is already given positive
momentum through the Strategic
partnership between our two regions
we want to work hard hand in hand with
you to address the biggest challenges of
our time
how we want to discuss today how to
further connect our people how to
further connect our businesses how to
de-risk how to strengthen and diversify
our supply chains and how to modernize
our economies in ways that reduce
inequalities and benefit all
all of this is within which if we get
the Marco Sewell EU agreement across the
Finishing Line our ambition is to settle
any remaining differences as soon as
possible so that we can conclude this
agreement and we want to be a partner
that has with you a win-win agreement of
which both sides benefit
in the meantime
I'm glad to announce that the European
Union will invest strongly in Latin
America and the Caribbean and we will
invest in a way that benefits local
communities and creates good jobs in a
few minutes we will open the Business
Roundtable
we will discuss with business partners
about these Investments and how to
achieve the best results once again a
very warm welcome here to Brussels it's
a pleasure to have you president Lula
review
for Brazil
it's very important very productive
to be back here at the European Union
our country spent six years
away from any kind of international
polit politics activities
neglecting the importance of good
diplomatic relations foreign trade
foreign foreign investment and we are
back into government in order to put
Brazil once again
as a protagonist in The International
Arena
economic activity is very intense in
Brazil right now and we want to share
that intense economic activity with our
partners in the EU
we want to share
all those benefits with our partners in
medical school in Latin American
Caribbean and even more importantly we
want to strengthen
with the European Union and the
discussion on not only Industrial
Development and growth but we want to
discuss the climate issue
everybody knows that Brazil has
a strong
focus on producing renewable energies
roughly 87 percent of our electricity is
from renewable sources we have 50 over
overall energy production is
renewable as compared to 15 in the rest
of the world and the energy and climate
transition is now a priority for our
government
I know this is a topic that is very
topical here in the European Union we
have a lot of interest in that
right now in August we prepared our
development
we're preparing our development
government and that will include an
important energy transition program and
we would like to share the European
Union to take part in that program
because
probably this is going to be the deepest
deepest energy transition program
established in a developing country
nowadays
as everyone knows Brazil will meet their
climate commitments we have a commitment
with zero deforestation in the Amazon
forest up to 2030 this is a commitment
that we had already stated during your
campaign and it can continue committed
to that
it's something we believe in not me
personally but the entire Brazilian
people believe in that and in this
debate we want the EU to understand the
need
to protect the the livelihoods of 50
million people living in the Amazon
forest they need to live in good quality
and this is why in the city of Berlin in
eight and nine August we will have a
great Summit involving all the Amazon
countries we also invited the two Congos
and Indonesia in order to discuss with
the world how to better preserve the
forests of the world
for me I'm really proud to be here today
and
talk to you about that with you
[Music]